what is that what is good we are back in
New York and we are back in the studio
and Sims what up how you feel I'm
feeling how are you do you like my shirt
I do like your shirt I'm actually kind
of annoyed by it why I mean [ __ ] I'm
only the one that started to calling the
greatest of all time you think the guy
who made the freaking shirt could get
meat one I'm a better t-shirt model is
what they told me right yeah I got a
green shirt with a white outline of a
goat with a yellow 12 it's air Rogers
the goat I don't know if it's available
yet in the Bleacher Report's store right
but I also had that Chucky Groot about
that I mean alright so it's my coach you
get the t-shirt I call the guy the
greatest of all time you're wearing a
t-shirt not with a hoodie on top and I
just didn't think you're a t-shirt guy
doing what he told me yeah what he's the
best yeah but I don't know when this
shirt gets available in the Bleacher
Report's store but keep an eye on it I
love it so trims thank you for letting
us all know that air Rogers the coat yes
you had a frustrating week man if people
listen to our podcast earlier and they
heard the issues with your travel write
it just continued throughout the entire
week it did your hotel room had drills
going on the entire time your room
service did not come you didn't have
running water right then God forbid I
have to travel with you want to flight
that one's too late don't forget the
hotel also didn't call Josh to wake them
up the morning we were leaving yeah
right it's a phenomenal hotel guys
Newport Beach Renaissance don't go there
Motel six will be better I promise this
morning them because and horrible it
shouldn't be in existence and then we're
flying back from California and of
course we tell them all I mean yeah see
here's the thing is I'm I'm only
enjoying all the delays because I'm
sitting behind Sims and I'm just seeing
him angrily shake his head we had to sit
there our gate wasn't ready there's
another fight there no JFK Airport they
only knew we were coming in for four
months four months but it was a shocker
to them it's an embarrassment to our
country that Airport and then they were
like oh sorry you know that little
pathway started that's not working I
yelled at everybody I did people leaving
the plane I did I said you gotta you
gotta yell at somebody somebody's got to
become accountable with this stuff and
he goes well LA is worse I go this place
sucks I know that and then when I walked
out I
yes then I said and then the guys doing
the the the bridge or whatever I think
it's the worst airport in the country
and they looked at me and they didn't
know what to say worse they don't know
what to say cuz you just store well
there somebody's got to be accountable
in that business I'm starting it and I'm
gonna yell at everybody until I find
who's accountable including the toll
people leaving the parking lot at JFK so
I get into one car and Sims gets into
another car and I'm like see you later
and I go to my driver ago that guy is so
angry right now he goes he seems it so
we're driving and we separate I thought
Sims is on his way to Connecticut I'm
going to Manhattan we're on a different
way and we get up to the tolls and I
just hear outside I don't know that was
and then I hear well you my driver goes
this guy's crazy and I look and what do
you know it was me blonde heads sticking
out the back of a car this guy is gonna
lose his mind I'm dying laughing yeah I
want to be entertained no problem that's
what I'm here for I wanted to go home I
wanted to watch the PGA Championship
because Tiger was I mean it's a six-hour
flight and then we spent an extra 45
minutes on the plane I mean that's
that's so messed up it shouldn't be
against their law it really should be
against the law and then we get to that
place and we get to the toll booth and
nobody moves for five minutes there's
seven rows of cars do and nobody moves
so yeah I lost it and then they were
doing changes and they were taking their
sweet old time so if you could tell us
it was upset guys I think it's because
our week of road trip went so well every
month I had to pay my penance for that
yes yes Saturday guys we get to hang out
with a few of the Rams really good time
Sean McVeigh was awesome big brain on
Sean McVeigh it's unbelievable he's like
I mean he's so so similar to John Gurdon
to me in a lot of ways it's like he
raised the hair on my neck he literally
shook my hand and went I listen to you
guys all the time Adam yeah and I went I
wouldn't believe you but how the hell do
you know my first name is I literally
introduced myself as lefke right so show
McVeigh is listening yeah maybe maybe
yes but I mean we got to hang out with
tio and Ochocinco MA
we just we have a lot of stuff brewing
right now that I'm excited to show you
guys and tell you guys just know that
all the best stuff from the podcast
we're taking it to another level when
the NFL season starts all right
so ACL epidemic what number do you think
we're up to already we've gotten one
week of preseason out of the way I'm
gonna say I feel like we were at 6 or 7
last week I'm gonna say we're at 11
we're at 17 are you kidding me yes geez
Giants defensive tackle Christian so
Kelly Rams cornerback Kevin Peterson
wash and running back Darius guys were
right right it's unfortunate because he
really didn't think he got hurt I know
it's but that happened to me it happens
a lot another Washington tight end
mattis a Gardner Indiana how do during
the game - I don't I think so yeah Colts
wide receiver Deon Cain rookie at a
Clemson I knew a lot of people were
excited I heard he was in good camp
Cardinal Center aq Shipley are up to 17
it's unbelievable I would love to know
just go throw them again because you
know the NFL's so concerned with player
safety it's all they care about you
should see what turf had happened yes I
mean the ones I feel like I've seen in
preseason at this point I've all been on
turf like you know who's one of the
healthiest teams no sim what's that
the Ravens surprise asked about the
Ravens good run of Health John Harbaugh
said you kind of leave things alone
sometimes not that we're superstitious
how does the old saying with Michael
Scott from the office go I'm not
superstitious I'm just a little stitches
he said that yes which is awesome but
remember the Ravens were the one that
eased into the season last year then all
the injuries haven't hardly had any
injuries all of their starters right now
are healthy right and I know that we
both believe this is what we just kept
looking at each other time with the
Ravens and being like I think we're
gonna pick the Ravens to win the north
and they're in the running I'm not gonna
say I'm definitely doing that but I do
expect the Ravens to be one of those
like if you maybe go all right you got
to put money on a team that didn't go to
the playoffs last year and has to go
this year I mean I think the two highest
guys in that car there's three teams
that come to your mind right away them
the Chargers right and probably Green
Bay those threes along because Rodgers
is back those three alone I just look at
and go they are prime suspects too
enter the playoffs this year and we're
out laughter who were the three that I
mean if they got to replace who were the
three people that are falling out oh
yeah okay so uh let's see it does it
stand true with what so I know the three
teams I think they're Buffalo
yes Buffalo I think you're gonna say
Kansas City a Kansas City
yes and that's mainly just because of
all the changes in the new opera and I
just think the West is better like that
with Gruden there yes the defense lost a
few players right it is a rookie
quarterback so yeah I'm looking at them
you said hello and then the Carolina
Panthers I think that's the other team I
would just be dicey about to a degree
all right so what we want to do today is
Sims had a chance on the flight back and
and really to dive into a lot of film
yeah for people that are watching the
preseason games I know for me I go on to
NFL game pass i watch the condensed and
then if I want to focus on any plays and
really zoom in I can do that but after
the first quarter for a lot of these
games unless you're invested into the
teams and you're looking for the
diamonds in the rough you're mainly
using week one to go a what does a
player look like in their Jersey right
like how'd it like if I talked about
them being big all like combine is that
do they still look big yes and then the
other thing is just quarterback play
yeah those are the things and some
rookies yeah right rookies quarterback
play yeah everything else is a mix and
match and you know summer starter some
are not and again I don't trying to
evaluate play I'm evaluating the look of
players
you can't evaluate play across the board
right you know for instance and we'll
get into this more Josh Rosen played the
Chargers and the Chargers played some
complicated defenses for bringing some
road dog they did all that and so he was
a little disadvantage with it let's
start right there okay sure right there
sure so I that because all the
quarterbacks I want you to kind of do
the reviews and I want you to go just
how they looked in the first week Lamar
Jackson two games will go 5 to 1 just
how they look so far ok let's start with
Josh Rosen cuz I think it's the game
that not a lot of people looked at yeah
I'm gonna give you my very elementary
observation good his the center snaps to
him we're like the worst of all the
rookie quarterbacks
he was constantly picking it up off his
shoes or whatever he was also the
quarterback I thought under the most
pressure yes let's get the Chris Sims
official review of Joshua I think both
of those are true
and both of those have to be taken to
into account first of all he's the only
one that really went against the
starting defense out of a football team
okay right so he played against the
starters like when he was in there
melvin ingram was in there and brandon
me bein were in there and the starting
line backers and corners were all in
there right Edgar came in the second
right darn 'old came in like the third
right and this was later
yes Lamar get gots got to come in second
in this game but yes so he had a deal
not only with that and then he had his
own it was the backup offensive line
versus the starters of the Chargers and
so that was a tough thing to be a part
of and I would say the Chargers did more
on defense coverage weijun coverage wise
and blitz wise than most teams I
watching the preseason
either way Rosen was very good I mean
Rosen's throwing is on point it's
effortless
he's got a good sip on the outside
exactly right it's pure every time he
moves in the pocket and has very good
feel within the pocket do I sit there
and go he's a step slow a little bit
still - yes but it doesn't mean anything
at this point would I like him to be a
hair quicker and maybe oh gosh there's
somebody coming let me get out and like
run a little hair quick right he can
learn that but out of all those guys he
is like maybe this step you know slowest
out of all that let me see if there's
anything more I thought that he has a
big been quality in him yes where he's
able to throw with people hanging on
he's a great bad foot throwing he had
two or three throws where it was looking
like looking like a sack but his upper
body was strong enough to get that 10
yard pass it is he's so mechanically
pure with his upper body and then that
allows him like you're saying like Oh
somebody's coming in my face he can lean
back on that back leg and not have to
step really far hard into the ball you
can kind of just rotate in place and
make it happen
and he was he was really on point for
the most part of the night I was
impressed with him yeah probably should
have thrown I think one interception got
dropped yes but even on the flat route
yes and then king could add a pick six
but again it's rookies and things are
gonna happen but overall I just say this
for a blanket statement before we dive
it overall like ultra impressed by
rookie quarterback I think all five
really long they look the part they're
not like deer in the headlights that's
where I look like the day and age of
well he needs a year to sit there it's
over they got too many reps in college
son seven everything so it is awesome I
really like it just my other notes from
the game as I'm saying it you can kind
of look over your yeah I thought
Christian Kirk showed a lot of giddy up
on that punt return and I like his body
in the uniform kind of like a Doug
Baldwin yeah he does you're right he
does David Johnson looked great mhm he
had two big runs what did you think of
David Johnson I thought so too and in
the starting old line for the Cardinals
I mean a little bit better than I
thought that it has potential Andre
Smith Justin pew yeah DJ Humphries is at
left tackle I you potty was in there
yeah they're big guys they are big guys
and fullback was in there leading the
way I mean those are things we haven't
seen a whole lot out of the Arizona
Cardinals with David Johnson I thought
that Jeremy Davis catch was unbelievable
as a Chargers and my only other thing
was there was a lot of bad helmet calls
in that game right I'm a little I'm a
little worried I'm not gonna lie let's
get into that yeah I mean I'm a little
worried just the way the games being
wrapped at this point there were two or
three calls in that game alone that were
like helmet into the chest right and
that it was helmet to the ball and they
called a member they made the tight-end
fumble and they called I don't know I
just all I have this discussion for like
the first few weeks of the year like
game-changing penalties I'm gonna suck
it's um it's stupid and I don't even
know I'm one of the cause if anybody out
there wants to watch it yeah San Diego
tie didn't catch the ball like LA
Chargers catch the ball off the left
seam safety hit some bumbles the ball
the guy took four steps so I don't know
if they called leading with the helmet
or you know receiver either way it was a
horrible call but yes I'm very worried
about that the length of the game and
two we haven't even seen the biggest
strongest most aggressive players on the
field yet for four quarters so how many
five should we any get and I would also
argue with these new rules they're gonna
harm the defensive players the defensive
players are gonna go I don't know what
to do when they're just gonna let people
run them over yeah they're gonna they're
gonna put their bodies in bad positions
because they're gonna be afraid to lower
their head to protect themselves or
whatever it may be Louis Riddick said he
says you know what I didn't see in the
first weekend by any of the offensive
players lower in their heads getting
called he goes because I saw a lot
it never gets called it defense of guys
are completely ripped off the offensive
guys are what caused the penalties on
the defensive guys because they're the
ones that
and then they have no choice but to let
me lower my body and again the optics of
a guy wearing a helmet right like if I
wanted to hit with this part of my head
right which is which is what they teach
you like hit with your forehead okay
when you do that you do this with the
optics of the helmets gonna look like
you're ducking your head sometimes and
you're really not you're just kind of
straight let me get with my face and
forehead exactly right they're kind of
doing the turtle yeah I mean a little
bit except you're doing it like this
where you're shrinking that the
shoulders in there with it all right so
let's go next to Sam darn 'old yeah and
the New York Jets okay New York Jets uh
man the the video coming out of that
touchdown where he kind of rolls right I
think was everywhere right another guy
that looked poised but let's get the
Chris Sims official sand Arnold
breakdown from this past weekend all
right I'm just gonna read a falcon yeah
I'm gonna just read my notes through
directly I mean I wrote just such good
feet that's the first thing I noticed
was Sam darling his feet are out of this
world that and really you can't play
this day and age in the NFL without it
but his ability to just make subtle
moves in the pocket or push up in the
pocket is what made them amazing at USC
and that carried over he's I wrote like
Baker Mayfield the ability to check the
rush and truly peak it like oh let me
see what the defensive end is and then
also then get his eyes back upfield to
look and read coverages it's off the
charts as far as that's concerned like I
almost think I'm amazed by that the how
they well both of them do it I am almost
think it's it's better not to rush say
I'm Donald I feel like he's almost
better yeah you really do think that was
the one of my critiques of AUSA when
when he was kept in the pocket and made
to make throws that was when he was at
his least best when the game became
chaos and he got to play background
bought backyard football scramble and
make off schedule throws he's an amazing
thrower the football really you saw that
right yeah I mean he's amazing at that I
just was the play calling was very
simple but either even to that he was
very decisive got the ball out of his
hand quick even for that funky motion I
mean he can get it out in a hurry when
he wants to and really made good
decisions the TD throw on the right side
I mean that was phenomenal again see
what he did there - just a nuance in a
little bit he looked to the left where
the scheme of the play was like this the
play was dialed up to go left he didn't
like the way it looked and he was taught
flipped
to the right side and we have a comeback
there so if you didn't like what you
like on the left you get over there
quickly and throw a ball towards the
sidelines high and outside where I got
our guy gets it or nobody gets it he
threw that right on point and again his
ability to see and reevaluate in a hurry
is what jumps out to my heart is it to
roll one way and have to throw it
further that way because that like to me
to roll right and have to throw it
further to the right yeah I think it'd
be a lot harder than coming across to
the left no it's it's still easier to
throw it farther to the right than it is
to go across just because at least
you're Momentum's taking it that way but
nonetheless an easy throw not an easy
throw and he's phenomenal throwing the
ball on the run and then I even wrote
that the TD the play before that there
was pass interference on a touchdown
that the play before and that was a
phenomenal throw as well but throwing on
the one the run is what really impresses
me about him and then his ability to hop
in the pocket and move and get out of
the way is the other thing I think that
makes him special so you were impressed
I was I'm not gonna come in here and say
that I wasn't impressed every rookie I'm
gonna tell you how impressed oh how
about Teddy yeah Teddy Teddy was good
Teddy okay
nothing special no great throws but made
some good decisions and good throws my
big thing with him would be this he's
still limping when he gives the handoff
or carries out a bootleg he does not
have a normal running pattern yet and
again it was a good start
made a few down throws as the game went
on threw the ball well but nothing that
was WOW but still a good start but I do
still I want to see more of him moving
with people around his legs and right
that that's probably the last piece of
the puzzle the good thing is is for
people that I've watched Teddy for a
long time he's not a runner anyone know
so this notion that oh he won't be able
to run a lot yeah well he wasn't running
he's always he runs horizontal and keeps
his eye he's like he's like Sam darling
he's great with in finding the pocket
and finding another little pocket within
the pocket you throw the football and
which is what's gonna be tough on his
knees because I want to see that cuz
that's those are jarring cuts you make
do you think that teams are watching his
film and go and maybe we should bring
him in I I would think so certainly okay
he was so he was good yeah oh yeah
definitely I mean he died
there's got to be a number of teams that
are gonna keep their eye on like a teddy
bridgewater like the Denver Broncos all
right you want to go there well I mean
yeah yeah that was it that was it
my first note that I'm gonna be a deep
dive he's got you're only playing one or
two three series right well Paxton Lynch
got booed off the field yeah our backs
at Lynch could have thrown the ball into
the ground and had a better passer
rating than what he did yeah he really
the put guys in danger a few times and
they led to interceptions and also got
his guys clocked right he had a few or I
felt like he looked at one read put his
head down and then got sacked yeah did
you see any growth out of Paxton Lynch
it wasn't very it was not encouraging I
mean it just it's it's bad pocket feel
it's staying in the pocket a hair too
long when you just want to go like abort
mission abort mission abort mission get
out go run make something he's an
athlete yes he is but he is standing
there a little bit too long yes that the
decision on the interception was you
know it got tipped in the air and people
at all we got on lucky no that was a
horrible decision so that's got to be
concerning there was nothing to build on
there from Paxton Lynch there really was
no where are you right now as a
quarterback evaluator that we're going
in the year 3 yeah he's in deep trouble
and I would question whether he's ever
gonna turn the corner of Foley I do yeah
I mean I you know we always thought
there was potential there and I'm not
saying it's over yet but I do think he's
endangered by being passed by a Chad
Kelly at this point who was far more
impressive than he was in the football
game was Case Keenum fine Case Keenum
was fine you know they played to series
yeah he really only threw the ball like
to legitimate throws one was complete
another one was pretty good coverage he
threw it high just be safe yeah and that
was it that was I'm not concerned let's
just you know let's pump you know let's
pump the brakes and everybody talking
about that people were excited with Chad
Kelly
in fact I walk down the aisle yeah
because you were watching film I was
watching film and I stopped and said
your boy Chad Kelly had some thrown
right and I didn't see it until this
morning so when you said that to me
everybody had told me that but I didn't
wasn't was bad yes but I thought that
man that guy's got some moves too he
does a good athlete all right so let's
get the Chris Sims Chad Kelly break down
Chad Kelly I mean all right so started
the interception the interception first
of all the the you know was it a
decision no but it wasn't the worst I
really think he misjudged the throw more
than actually just like made a bad
decision he saw the guy there he just
didn't make the proper throw which I
don't doc as much points off for the guy
who throws it over the middle was like
oh my gosh there was a guy there yeah
and then you go damn well you're not
seeing the field there if you didn't see
that guy but other than that I mean I
would argue yeah he played up there with
I mean he was one of the most impressive
quarterbacks of the weekend because he
made some big-time throws and made some
throws into tight windows and then his
running was very impressive very berry
now he should have thrown another
interception that was a pick six to the
right side and one of the last drives
right but that's Chad Kelly and again
he's young but I think there's something
to build on but that's why I said
Denver's got to be a team that's got to
be looking at Teddy Bridgewater their
asses are on the line out there they
can't be we're gonna depend on Paxton
Lynch and Chad Kelly and John Elway's
asses on the grill
vans Joseph's ass on the grill right
they're gonna go oh yeah we feel good we
can make a run with Paxton Lynch or you
know Chad Kelly Chad Kelly has potential
I don't think you want him as your
backup yet you run him as your third and
your backup for next year right and then
maybe he becomes the starter in year
four or five whatever that is but that
would be the gameplan for me there but
yes I got to think that would be the
type of team that would be looking go
ooh we need a little bit more of an
experienced guy who can rely on to be
knocked back set his arm but I think
Chad's got the strongest arm on that
team I do I would agree
Chad can really fling it I mean really
if I wish he would tighten up his motion
maybe a little bit but as a whole yes I
mean some of those throws he made he
made a little in cut over the middle
into a window that was I mean the size
of the goat on your shirt there and he
fired it in there uh is it am I crazy I
know it was one drive but I thought Kirk
Cousins running the Minnesota offense it
was the best of Minnesota offense looked
even better than any game last year yeah
like I got done watching that drive and
maybe it was where he put that Diggs
throw but I left and went people have
been sleeping on Kirk Cousins
and I think if they think that he's
equal to case keenum
they don't know what they're talking
about yeah I would say that too I came
away going oh this off
could really be improved even after a
great year they had last year yeah he's
a pure thrower he's like crazy for
nothing that none at all he's better
than Case Keenum for people to say that
they're equal that's disrespectful to
Kirk Cousins Case Keenum the only he's
probably a little bit better athlete
than Kirk cousin but he doesn't have a
quick release Kirk's ability to evaluate
and like one blink of an eye and just
make that throw is what makes him
special and yes when you put it with the
offense that this protection run game
got a scheme he's gonna do all the work
he's gonna know exactly where everybody
is on offense and he can be surgical and
that's what he was in that game maybe I
got a little too excited watching
Minnesota but I came away feeling a few
things one Rock Thomas is a nice little
running back they got that kid out of
Jacksonville stay out so I didn't watch
him closely but I got you but I see the
bursts right and I go okay Dalvin cook
latavius Murray Rock Thomas you got some
good backfield guys there and then I'm
seeing this at a digs and Thielen and
and the backup offensive lineman for
Minnesota was pushing people get the
look they got the look I do they they
have the look and you know the defense
is gonna be good yeah but I look at that
offense and go I I kind of want to
invest a lot in Minnesota they just made
me feel really comfortable and I also
looked at Denver and went man I really
don't see it yeah I don't see the horses
up front and Bradley Chubb looked okay
in the uniform and all that but the
depth of the d-line was not there I know
and and again this is where I was
freaking preseason week want to get to
exam I know because the where I always
try to tell people like this this is
what you don't know about pre shooting
this one let me straight Minnesota
might a game planned right they'd be
like we got to make sure our ninety
million dollar guarantee quarterback
gets actually good luck right and Denver
might have been like we're only gonna
play these one or two defenses and we're
only gonna run these ten plays on
offense so that's where it can become
misleading because one team might be
gone I'm gonna make it hard on my guys
and the other team's gone I want to give
my guys some confidence as we get
through here so there are different
stages of your development as a football
team and that's where you just got to be
careful at times over value in here
right but it was a good start by cousins
it was weird for me for Minnesota that
Chad Beebe Don Beebe son was playing
wide receiver and wearing 84 Randy Moss
and I'm going one why is anybody wearing
84 just retire it right and two little
white boys Supreme Chad Bibi over here
of all people is funny all right let's
go to another rookie quarterback let us
go to we kind of talked to Manziel we
kind of knot Manziel that that's bad I
apologize
let's go Josh Allen okay because I feel
like the there's a there's a epidemic
going on right now other than the ACL
epidemic which is people are enjoying
making fun of Josh ow yeah they're gonna
get made fun of in the end of the day
here's where we are as a football
watching community a lot of the
analytics world this is the road or
world a good part of NFL reddit and a
lot of people that that love accuracy
and those statistics and all that and
I'm not every statistic is valuable have
not like Josh Allen at all his
statistics were so bad in college he was
very erratic and they didn't like the
excuses of the lack of town around him
or the offensive line it there was a bit
of fact that he played in blizzards and
everything like that and they say that
people like yourself are wowed by the
physical abilities and the arm strength
and that he'll never be able to gain the
accuracy and what has turned into is
there is a war on the internet about
Josh Allen the one throw in training
camp that went over the guy's head he
was mocked for eternity even when their
reports saying that he was the most
impressive player at camp the throw that
he was trying to elude people on third
long or fourth and long and he kind of
threw it away became another running
meme making fun of them right what did
they want him to do there though tell me
what they wanted to do it was it was
last year three and the guy wasn't
blocked on the end of the line of
scrimmage which he's not in charge of
blocking people now - I watched on
YouTube every throw from Josh Allen yeah
and I was in the back of the car on the
way to a shoot going Sims this is
incredible I came away going there were
six throws that Josh Allen made in that
game that were better than every throw
of the other rookie quarterbacks
combined there was three runs he made
that I would put up against Lamar
Jackson's best runs and I'm sitting here
going there's a large
contingent of the football watching
community that is making fun of Josh
Allen and they're missing all of the
great plays yes what did you see against
Carolina with Josh yeah I mean first of
all wait wait you mean oh no the
internet doesn't think he's doing well
here's what's crazy to me Sims and this
is the why I'm giving it grants you mean
against the part of the internet though
that I trust it's the part of the
internet that has been right many times
and they're the ones saying that Josh
Allen like there I don't get it because
I trust a lot of the rotor world guys
but they hate Josh Allen and I don't get
it I don't get it either I don't really
know i mean i think bias plays into
those guys cuz they've hatched their
wing and wagon to some other guy we're
biased about stuff too I get that we're
very but but to sit there and just like
not say somebody or you know makes on
social news like fun of a guy all the
time I've never seen anything like it
it's disrespectful it's stupid and all
these people they better watch out
because they're they're gonna come back
and have to eat their words first of all
I just don't care what a lot of those
people say second of all the game was
very impressive I mean oh I know he
threw a 63-yard football out of bounds
by three feet okay who's this first
throw ever as an NFL football player how
dare he missed that I mean how dare and
you want to know the first thing the
first thing about that nobody was more
excited in that game when he went in
than the bill sidelines so that to me
what do you mean take oh I love that
that's that just tells me right there
that they think he's a baller because
when he made that first throw the whole
sideline erupted and then when you look
at the ends I endzone cut in the ball
you know the guy goes out of bounds and
he only got like he didn't get any feet
in but it was close everybody it was
like whoa and they were looking at
Joshua Allen ago and they were hopping
around look at that man throw the ball
that's what they were doing so they
don't do that for something like slap
dick who they don't think worth a [ __ ]
okay all right so second thing he had
two drops in the football game
is he perfect no he's a little raw still
certainly but men I also saw again the
greatest raw ability out of all the
quarterbacks like you said that the rose
some of the throws were phenomenal and
he did have to drop and they were on the
one losing first down right one was
gonna hit the prole kid right in the
hands yes that's funny that BB was
playing and
fine right but regardless I think
between that and then the big thing like
you said the movement oh my god I would
say the movement and the amount of
broken tackles and the runs he had has
been better than anybody better than
Lamar Jackson he yes he's done that I
mean he drew the corner every time he
did and we're done where the linebacker
was running right at him and he just
stepped to the left and the remade the
linebacker look stupid right and then
turns it upfield for another eight ten
yeah I know I mean he is so big and so
fearless in the pocket and you get to
see a variety of throws Carolina D doing
more and I hadn't watched the rosin game
to this point I wrote more than any
other rookies had to deal with the
Carolina played some different defenses
to it was not very middle I mean not
very what did I want to say remedial yes
exactly whatever and then I wrote he is
such a gifted thrower and then I wrote
not just power Adam I wrote underneath
it in case you read the notes because I
know everybody's always thing so I'm
worried about power oh he's got a strong
warm I know I know which is the dumbest
thing ever
arm strength matters very much but he
makes all the throws touch throws you
see everything that you need to see so
it's not just about power it's some of
the effortless throws he makes like
there's a swing route he throws to the
right oh man and I mean the way he
throws it like nobody could do what he
did except Aaron Rodgers and maybe a
Patrick mahomes and that was a thing
this kind of players like I actually
want to bring up the clip so you can
watch it and just go so you know I did
so what was amazing to me was I like to
compare the swing routes to the running
back for all the guys because when I
watched Josh Allen throw the ball right
the running back had such more
opportunity for yak yes
whereas Myers yeah when I watched like
Sam Darnell dumping it out or or Josh
Rosen you know Josh Rosen's got some
good zip yeah but really Allen gets to
him so quick Allen's arm is as strong as
I've ever seen it really is I've never
seen anybody throw it is hard to keep
track of the ball on television it's
hard to keep track of the ball on film
too it's the same type of thing I mean
it's it's it's a special arm and really
let me just make sure I said everything
yeah I broke definitely has to plays
where he's just too aggressive and
trying to stick it in there I wrote he's
still raw but overall good his raw
ability is jaw dropping some of the
throws and runs he has strode so strong
I wrote an underline better be careful
because he's reminded me of Carson Wentz
he doesn't think anybody can tackle him
and he can do anything and that's what
scares me about those guys because
they're so physically gifted and they've
been breaking tackles their whole life
that they think oh I can still do this
in the NFL after I've done it a few
times so that's what I always worry but
again I still think it was a very
encouraging start for him and I wanted
to get that throw because I want to just
show it to you because I think it was
phenomenal and I think this is it coming
up right here yeah I mean I just want to
show it one more time I'm sorry and you
can react too alive but this I mean
these are just little situation if
people want to watch it at home okay
here we go going this quarter
okay third quarter and there's just
little things okay so third and eight
right ball is on the 16 with 559 left in
the game if you guys want to go on there
you ask yeah third quarter this is the
play right so I'm really what I'm just
impressed is again I'm just looking I'm
evaluating people and their talent but
I'm going to show you the endzone view
like Aaron Rodgers the only guy that
I've seen can do this like his feet are
gonna be pointing this way to north and
so and then he just flicks it over there
with his feet off the ground he's
hopping as he's doing it look yeah and I
mean it's a laser and the defense can't
even get they can't even react to it
quick enough now it doesn't go to our
first down but it made it gave their
running back a fighting chance to go get
it which then the next play was the
fourth and three oh my gosh they
shouldn't have drafted him nobody was
open and there was nothing to do on
fourth and three and he threw the ball
up in the air in his second drive of his
career ever
what an idiot let's get rid of him I'm
sick of Twitter and their idiot
responses I don't know what else to say
let's take it we always take advantage
yeah every all of our listeners the one
that dm's me the ones that DM me and the
ones that write on YouTube that go I
used to watch other people and now I
realize that I can't just listen guys
just look around see who's saying things
that you're dumb hey maybe you might be
a bust he might end up being a bus but I
know right now I can't tell and if I
can't tell none of the hell you other
people can tell Ravens Lamar Jackson
yeah did
you see anything in the second game that
you didn't see in the first game because
we did the first game um I thought he
threw the ball better at this game
I wrote Lamar early throwing ball well I
do think he needs to put some more
mustard on some of his aggressive throws
he's too relaxed and he's getting away
with throws because he's going against
second and third stringers like the seam
you saw to the left side where the guy
made a great catch right now right like
that play I was a loopy if he doesn't
watch it remember he got the tight end
hit in the Hall of Fame game of a
similar one to the right side the week
before it if he doesn't want easy to
uncork the rice he's got to let it go
he's gonna learn that that's got that
ball has to be thrown with pace because
this is not College anymore and the free
safety is gonna knock those guys out and
nobody didn't want to run seam routes
for Lamar Jackson but I think you know I
would I say lofting throws second week a
lot of different angle arm angles in the
second week I think that was really
impressive to me his ability to duck
down and throw around linebackers and
things like that and almost throw the
ball sidearm sometimes I think he throws
the ball better and with more velocity
when he does that then when he tries to
throw it proper because he doesn't get
himself in good position always when he
tries to throw a proper he tries to get
over the top his front leg locks out is
kind of technical looks like he's you're
getting too much yes cuz I don't think
he really feels comfortable when he's
just sitting there normal to go let me
throw my hundred power I'm a hundred
mile per hour fastball but then when he
gets out of the pocket or has to change
his arm angle he's willing to just let
it go and those are some of his best
throws let me just see I'm pressing on
this mobility his mobility was very good
it really was again he had some people
in there with him that the defense had a
worry about this time so it created some
running lanes right where I argued the
first time they had a running game this
time some of the receivers in there that
were scaring people so that created
space for the linebackers go oh I got to
get downfield to cover the tight end
whatever it is and then he made some
runs the Ravens were another team that I
left and went man they look like a
really good unit right now yeah the
Ravens are a watch out team Flacco
looked good too though Flacco was
phenomena can say now
Flacco was starting the whole year I
think so I mean Lamar has shown some
little bursts and rg3 is looked good at
but like flacco look great yes Flacco
looked great and he moved out the pocket
we looked at each other like man this
guy looks like it yeah yeah he's he's
motivated he's got two guys there that
are pressing them every day and he knows
this could be his last leg and I think
this team is motivated as well and I
think they're gonna be good that's why I
say it's hard for me to look at it and
go oh Lamar Jackson will start at some
point during this year now the other
thing like Lamar his base package of
plays he got to run it's basic I mean it
really is it's even too basic for me and
preseason week number one this is the
other thing I want to say though about
him and these are little things that I
think that people will miss that he
brings value to the game I think when
he's in the game you're gonna see
running backs get bigger runs for two
reasons I mean the the offensive
lineman's ability to get the second
level is easier with Lamar Jackson in
there because linebackers always
hesitate when he gives the ball right he
gives the ball to the left and then they
stop for a second because they go Oh is
he booting out the other side and they
stop and all of a sudden oh he they did
give it hand it up and they tried to run
together running back and they called in
the Lyman's already there to get them so
those are some of the value of like
things that people won't go notice I
mean I won't go notice my people it's
not gonna be on the stat sheet but again
those are the little things that like a
Russell Wilson and him and Cam Newton do
to a team they always make you
second-guess or you're a hair later to
evaluate because you go Tim they're a
little dangerous on the edge I got a
watch out and those are the things I saw
a few times with a run game you were
very complimentary of Orlando Brown yeah
saying that he looked really really good
when you went and studied the tape yeah
little note on on Orlando Brown yeah
Orlando Brown at the combine weighed 338
he's now up to 350 but his body fat went
from 23% to 19% yeah he was never in his
uniform he's gained 12 pounds I've lost
four percent body fat right just could
be a third-round pick that they had that
could really exceed expectations and be
the future of that friend oh yeah yeah
the very worst he's their backup right
tackle this year and they're fine but
he's gonna be the starting right tackle
within the next two years I do believe
that their guys if they can stay healthy
that old line is deep and they look good
and then I think the other thing we got
to talk about would that game and just
in a hole and he didn't get to play a
lot but rg3 again I thought
was very good rg3 it's throwing is
special I just want people to know that
it's special the way he can whip the
ball around the field
he throws a perfect spiral every time he
can make a throw with his feet in any
type of angle it is a special arm and
I'm glad to see him doing well I really
am
Baker Mayfield you had a chance to go
back and really watch the film yeah from
what we saw at we were very
complimentary of his feet of his arm he
looked really comfortable out there did
anything change after you watch the film
against the Giants no closely I think
the thing is I mean I I you know again
I'm looking at quality of play more than
anything I wrote ball coming out clean
the movement in the pocket is top-notch
and top-notch even just the subtle
movements to just kind of step and dip
your shoulder out of the way to give
yourself a little room and I wrote like
I said with Sam darling he's great at
peaking at the rush and then getting his
eyes back up down the field and he's got
it I mean I don't know a lot of people
that have been able to really pull that
off but through the ball well great in
the pocket didn't have to read anything
would be the thing I would push back on
I didn't count for sure but I'm pretty
sure the Giants played man-to-man every
single snap of the whole game the Giants
are trying to figure out if they got any
other cover guys other than the juniors
Jenkins and right now I would say they
don't and so they better be careful but
yes he didn't have to ever go to like
the second or third read other than
maybe the touchdown throw that he lost
it over the middle of than Joe ku which
was this which was a great play but yeah
everything else was very easy oh it's
one on one let me throw the slant to
Antonio Callaway those type of things
but still an impressive showing by him
and the Giants secondary is a little
concerning like legit like Eli Apple and
Eli Apple and Darian Thompson at free
safety me that would really scare me Eli
Apple I have no confidence in and Darian
Thompson slow so you won't even a so
what did you see in the film that
enhanced your no confidence I mean Eli
let up a few catches in the game one was
like a back shoulders right side but
even he wasn't even close to making the
play I give you the benefit the doubt if
you're all over the guy I think I just
makes a great throw a great catch now he
wasn't even really close to there to be
made to a play Jerry and Thompson this
seam we saw by a joke ooh first of all
alcohol good
three I will say look to step slow which
was also concerning first week yeah I'll
just say from there I was like he did
not look as fast at me but Darien
Thompson in the middle of the field him
and Landon Collins they're both like
bigger type safeties joke who caught a
seam up the right sideline it wasn't
like it was the rocker and Thomson he
outran no that was oval tree outran
Darian Thompson for the free safety that
never got over there I mean I mean Tyrod
looked at um he threw it over there and
he still couldn't even make a play on it
that would be concerning to me if I'm
the Giants of the five so this is first
week preseason game looking in their
uniform how they throw can I just get a
1 through 5 from 5 to 1 of just overall
impression and an impressive nosov it
yeah sure I think I was in last just of
the 5 it's not last they're all gonna be
they all were good yeah they were who
was the least impressive of the 5 I
think Lamar this week was the least
impressing to me he's he of all the
quarterbacks the one you can bet on will
not be starting this season yes
if the quarterbacks healthy agree what
about number 4 alright I'm number 4
I might go Josh Allen for the rosin or
Allen it's yeah I'd probably go rosin
rosin number of rosin number 4 and it
was 3 Allen number 3 I'm gonna go Sam
Donald - wow it was very clean right you
know Allen I just looked at it and go he
did have those two throws that I thought
were a little dicey so I'm taking away
I'm not taking it away for the 4th and 3
or the 62 yard bomb that was a foot and
a half out of bounds I know he should
have thrown it in bounds but I'm not
gonna go oh your first throw ever you
suck and then I'm gonna get Baker
Mayfield Top Billing
really yeah I am it's just he was the
guy I questioned what he would look like
the most and just again I was so
impressed with all their demeanor but
his demeanor just moving in the pocket
big-time throws everybody's sitting
there waiting to hate on him I feel like
to go like oh see he shouldn't have been
the first big play tie rod stop yeah
exactly right so I think that's how I
would go with it after everything yeah
so the two guys you had fourth and fifth
before the draft come out first and
second yes they did in their first game
right self Scout self scout scout
all right you also watched some guys
that are gonna be kind of big names
Patrick mahomes
yep
deshaun Watson right again it was
limited snaps right
but how did my Holmes look what did you
think my thought he was under attack by
the Texans deal I think that's the first
thing I wrote chief so line was not good
when he was in I mean he was he was
under attack he got hit a lot Texans are
a team yes watch out for like no cuz if
number four is really hitting on all
cylinders you're right and their defense
looked as scary it's scary they have
killers they don't go out there to
tackle you they go out there to kill you
so I was my home's handling all that he
was good it was hard there was nothing
to really evaluate like and just go oh
wow he looks the part the ball didn't
come out of his hand real clean just
from and I really you know I slow it
down and watch in slow motion
he just wasn't comfortable all the way
he never got a chance to really get in
flow of the game but I'm not I'm not
concerned or anything it was very
limited in this first time out and then
deshaun Watson yeah Watson I mean the
only thing Watson made one real good
throw he definitely has a little hitch
in his giddyup as well it's not a
hundred percent and I didn't want to see
more throws because I even thought his
mechanics on his one throw looked a
little off with his knee still made it
really nice throw and got it and he's
talented so you can overcome with that
but I just want to see more of it to go
who is this gonna be a problem later on
yeah I was just taken aback covington
reader on that deal I the Texans were
like all over the place and you realize
like we don't even really have clowny
and JJ Watt in the game and merciless
and merciless and like Tyrann Mathieu
running around like that that team is
really something yeah as a bunch of
brute cavemen and they also have a left
go sprinkle ooh there was a guy when I
was watching that I mean he caught my
attention not just because he caught two
touchdowns yeah I went where is this guy
coming from Jordan Aikens that kid at
tight end right to me look like
something special yeah I I can't say
that I watched closely there so I'm just
gonna tell you I forgot he was a he was
a third-round pick at a UCF mhm and this
kid was a third-round pick in the MLB
Draft a few years ago and that's why he
was 26 when he came out right did 29
reps at his pro day because I watched
this kid and I go oh this is the missing
piece for the Texans offense right like
we like Steven Anderson whatever like
there
okay yeah but this Jordan Aikens kid I
don't know I want you to check him out I
will this is like a six five six six
tight end
that's an athlete I don't know no and
some that keep an eye on they need
another weapon in the past game you can
rely on willfull exactly or Braxton
Miller nobody's even reliable to this
point so you've only had meetings with
those guys and then a true tight end yes
with your running back I'll check it out
I did not look close like I said I was
trying to evaluate some of the other
guys and the quarterbacks and get
through it so I didn't look at some of
those type of players cordarrelle
Patterson and jeremyhill looks real good
for the Patriots yeah I mean they're
everything I've heard from cordarrelle
is it's been impressive up there do you
think all of a sudden the light can just
turn on for him or do you think that
this is do you think that Minnesota fans
are and Raiders fans are going oh no we
heard this in training camp - yeah it's
kind of like that special a s I think
that like he's gonna be a huge
contributor with special teams
I would think New England had a very
like concise plan on what they wanted to
do with them and how they wanted to
indoctrinate him into the offense
altogether right so I'm sure they've
made it simple and they're gonna
continue to do that until they feel he's
comfortable it's New England they always
have a plan I know that you had a rookie
stand out to you for the Seahawks yeah
regime green the defensive linemen at a
USC I believe he was a second-round pick
right
he was number 94 at USC ground
third-round sorry he's 94 with the
Seahawks - he is in a big time sack he's
a player he's a guy that I really looked
at and thought he could be a Michael
Bennett ish type up higher when they
drafted him because in college a lot of
times he had to play defensive tackle
he's not really a D tackle he's a d n so
now he could be that d end on first and
second and I'm third down he's probably
to go inside get a mismatch on a guard
and abused them in the past game but
yeah he jumped out in that football game
and I think he'll be a big contributor
right away from them and I like relay
Rashad Penny look - yeah talk about
Rashad yeah I mean he only had a few
carries but again just the movement one
of the runs he got like five or six
yards he's very patient he reminds me of
I mean I know it's the same number and
it's like a cop-out
he reminds me of Natron means except
he's quicker and faster I think he's
more of a home run hitter than an e-tron
means but has that similar skate across
the ground type of running until he kind
of sees the hole and then he runs get
tremendous feat for a bigger guy I don't
know if you've watched tennessee green
bay yet but now what i thought was
interesting this is it's all off seasons
been video of Malcolm Butler picking
people off right and very early on
Davante Adams was one on one with him
yeah and just burned him did he burned
him I think Davante Adams is gonna have
a major you would not be shot major year
he made a steam and he had a good year
last year great year last year really
good but I saw that and then also Harold
Landry had some great been to get around
for a sack I'm talking about like
horizontal on the ground he's amazing he
I iced this guy did this move and I went
whoa who was that and then I was like
damn it's [ __ ] Harold and yeah that's
awesome
yeah I have not watched one second of
that game yet so it was impressive yeah
I'll get there did you watch eagle
Steelers well I watched the first all
luck we just got to talk about lazy
right look and your luck right I mean
again it was two drives maybe three
whatever I can't remember exactly but
the only thing I wanted to go is pop on
the ball or the mechanics different it's
all I cared about and they weren't and
that's the best part about it what they
weren't they looked the same as they
were it looked like old Andrew Luck to
me the way he was throwing the football
there's nothing different there you know
the arm was good it's not an arm that
Wow's you but it's a really good arm
that can make every throw in football
but you used to have a WoW arm well no
he never had a WoW arm he has a WoW
ability to throw the ball down the field
and be right on the money but you're
talking 15 minutes 15 yard intermediate
routes yeah he doesn't have like a laser
he's not like he's not like Rogers or
yeah or Josh or whence or some of those
guys that can like when they want to
throw a laser like what if he's throwing
that bomb the T why he could really get
he is amazing a dude no saw yeah look
right look like luck Wow
yeah movin in the pocket all of it look
phenomenal
it really did I have a song with a shirt
off I'm him I know Jenna met six
legitimate I can't I have a hard time
thing anybody other than that Cam Newton
is gonna look like that would
shirt off a quarterback in the NFL right
can you think anybody that would look
like that
I don't but he looks good I'll tell you
the guy that popped to me and I'm gonna
give it to our guy hey Quinn what's up
man
Marlon Mac I'm just over running back he
got banged up I know but he looked good
did he he did I mean I would say he'd be
a guy to watch out for in this offense
you know your Philly offense there it is
interesting with with Marlon Mac and
Nayeem Heinz and Wilkins they got a
bunch of young running backs that I
don't think anyone knows who's gonna be
the guy good combo though I think Eagles
Steelers our guy Josh sweat I was very
impressed yeah I haven't watched that
one at either because they're just what
you know then I thought Dallas Goddard
looked the part - yeah it's Goddard okay
what he hurt his elbow yeah he's fine
okay yeah I saw the highlights of got
hurt he did look the part I'm looking at
juju and I'm going out judo was not a
fluke like some of the plays he was
making the blocks he that he could be a
future star in this and yeah I think
maybe he is I know he's a I just wasn't
sure how high of hopes to have for it I
know I guess I know you know that he
might be a DeAndre Hopkins ish type
maybe he gets to that and I know people
think or don't like DeAndre Hopkins no
DeAndre Hopkins is really good don't get
me wrong I just don't think he's like in
the class of a B Julio and Odell and
that crew but like juju his size his
physicality his ability to catch the
ball with people around him and doing
that he's just a physical specimen I
think that's what I when I watched the
Pittsburgh I'm always just like man look
at him - connects safety and he's just
fearless you saw the guy trying to sneak
on the Steelers practice okay I thought
Troy has that ever happened before
we're fans somehow got on the field I
can't remember that ever happening I
really I wish he would have got out
there verb play that would have been
great I wish you but I think people need
that little check sometime I would love
to I would have loved them to go let me
go check Antonio Brown at 11 on 11 drill
and they do a toss sweep - they're
running back right at them yeah let's
see it play tackle football let's see
few other random stories Antonio
Callaway we talked about how good he
looked yeah
disciplining him by making him play 54
snaps is that typical so this is the
wide receiver for Cleveland got in
trouble with Merrill
some Bart's guns in his car right and
the team disciplined him by making them
play a lot I I totally want to call
[ __ ] all right so there's two things
first of all it is real that they would
discipline you by making you play so
you've seen that before yeah because the
ballers like they want to be ballers and
they want to be like I'm the first or
second team and then I'm out hanging
with the homies on the sideline and
we're watching the other scrubs out
there where I cue my gum or you know
spit sunflower seeds eat hot dogs or hot
dogs but yes I certainly would have done
in my day a lot of people do yes every
season hey you gotta know how to go to
get him in the halftime yes
see and that's the best part at halftime
nobody knows where they are it's only
this vets that know yeah and you got to
go back in the training room they keep
them back there that's where I used to
go but yes
what the hell away Calloway ah to me I
take it as more they can say that as
punishment it's called they're getting
him in shape so he's ready in week three
when he misses the first two games from
suspension that's what I look at it and
go they're gonna make sure he's ready to
go when he's come back and you're gonna
see him play a whole lot the next one it
was to get the fan base to go listen I
know you're saying cut this guy we need
to show you what he's capable of so that
you don't beg for to be some of that too
could be he could take a slant 50 yes we
don't have a lot of guys that can do
that kid could be that certainly and he
was really good I'm not gonna sit here
and go like oh wow superstar no like
he's not as explosive as a DJ more or
some of those guys but still he's a
starting NFL receiver and can be really
damn good and then Ramsey and Fowler
getting suspended because Fowler Ramsey
was yelling at the media for defending
Fowler saying that he was getting too
tough coverage and they're both
suspended for a preseason well and then
Ramsey I mean you can't yell at the
media to stop filming I mean what are
you like Donald Trump I'm gonna control
the media now that's right yeah well you
know what it's like these teams think
that they have can especially the
players they run everything I know I
mean again a fight and an NFL training
camp when men are with each other 24/7
for 20-plus days in a row and you're all
seeing each other fights like that
happen all the time
you just hope they don't happen in the
middle of the
yield when it's that easy it's the end
of practice and it's that easy to
shatter New York Jets in Washington got
a fight right I mean those are going to
happen they always do those type of
fights that we just saw with Dante
Fowler and Yannick and Gok way I mean
those are the things that you hope
happen in the locker room and they
happen a lot in a locker room where guys
are like yeah one thing said they're
testy and then get into a verbal
argument and then they want to throw
blows seeing at training camp this week
I completely understand why they're
fighting it is hot as hell out there
yeah and I wasn't even wearing pads and
you're getting yelled at by coaches the
entire time I see why I could fighting
for your job Dante Fowler sitting there
it's the second day of practice first of
all it's hard to stick up for him in
this instance since he's the one that
got suspended for the week and Dante
Fowler how many fights has he been in I
mean he's gonna be suspended for the
first game because of some fight he had
out in the public anyways right
so that Yannick and Gok way I'm probably
looking at Dante going dim you made all
this money and I'm the guy you're
supposed to be I'm the one getting all
the sex I'm the third pick of the draft
and you're gonna wear it is it to mend a
relationship as teammates after they'll
get it over it quick yeah but like I
take it hard for me it's gonna take a
week in the NFL locker room and then
just someone go like she cans it'll just
happen where something will happen good
football wise or whatever and they'll
they'll brush it under the rug now they
might always look at each other at the
corner of their eye to it agree but it's
not gonna become an issue it's just hey
those are some bad asses on that defense
you would they are the league leader and
alpha males on one defense the last
thing you want to do is is kind of lock
them up did the Seattle Seahawks used to
fight with each other all the time I
remember it keep till even the Broncos
fighting with each other too so that's
what happens when you have that many
studs on the table I can't believe I
almost forgot this
right the Eagles sign Christian
Hackenberg
and I don't know what the thing what did
we always say I mean it's they got a
seat take a look at him oh because me
and our Scout said he was good five
years ago and some team picked him in
the second and I know everybody thinks
he sucked that seen him in person but
we're gonna take a chance this is what
drives me crazy about quarterbacks that
are high round pick you know why the
Eagles are doing this why
they want Christian Hackenberg to get a
Super Bowl ring before dak Prescott
that's what's gonna happen
Hackenberg is gonna make this roster and
he's gonna be a Super Bowl champion and
the Eagles are gonna win back-to-back
and they're gonna go oh you like dak
well we got Christian Hackenberg a Super
Bowl before Dec press yeah that's the
reason that's the reason they're gonna
keep this guy as one of the 53 just to
get him a ring and go we could beat you
guys with 52 spots on our roster and 53
sold Hackenberg what do you think I I
think he's just a camp arm I think a
camper yeah cuz son fell didn't falls
were banged up but the problem is is now
the the receivers are just gonna be
working on catching balls 10 yards over
their head it's bad ball drill bad ball
drill Thank You Barry I was so surprised
when that happened I I wasn't wasn't but
yeah I did think that the fact that he
had like a cup of coffee with the
Raiders basically that the rest of the
league would be like oh okay now it's
the Jets and the Raiders and the Jets
gave him two years of doing nothing
before they finally let it go so yes
it's just a camp baram he's getting one
more shot we'll see all right I'm gonna
finish it up with three random questions
from one of our followers Peter Chu
Peters said I have some weird football
questions but they're very simple but
they're questions that I would never ask
you I've never thought of these okay
first one is when teams have home games
do they sleep at their own homes
because when the Niners have a home game
they come off a team bus yes/no most
teams I believe actually all of them now
in the NFL sleep at a hotel so then why
do they show up in a bus because when
they well they might leave on a bus from
the hotel at a home game you're saying
that a home game yeah they can do that
where guys go on the bus at the hotel
they might not want to drive to the game
or do any of that because their wife's
gonna meet them at the game and their
girlfriends gonna bring the car or
whatever so then they go in the team bus
not everybody does that you know what
happens in a home game right you get up
in the morning let's just say it's a 1
o'clock Eastern game and you're here on
the East Coast you get up you're
probably gonna get up and around like
7:30 right something like that
you're gonna eat breakfast somewhere
between eight and nine thirty and then
at your house no it's taking them
usually at the facility it's usually I
mean at the hotel they're gonna have a
huge room even though you're at home
you're staying in a hotel definite yeah
that's what I was just saying it's I
just said you you weren't listening to
me you said that they sleep at home no I
said some teams used to sleep at home
but I think everybody in football sleeps
at a hotel at their homes yes
everybody's you like that yeah I think
it's necessary I do think it's nice I
think it's the smart thing to do my dad
would Dan Reeves
at the end of his career they the
veterans could stay home and he used to
be home on Saturday night and I always
thought it was so weird because I wasn't
used to it he's he's like in that
mindset and you're like dead yeah he's
like worried about red you white the
next day but yes I think every team
stays in a hotel during home games they
justic yes and then you have breakfast
at the the the hotel banquet room or
whatever some guys might get up and just
get up and go home and their wife cooks
them breakfast Wow but I think for the
most part guys eat it at the hotel they
take their time and they drive over the
stadium and get to the stadium let's say
you know ten o'clock 10:30 somewhere in
that range all right didn't know that
yeah that's why I like these questions
number two all the coaches on the
sidelines have headsets can all of them
communicate with each other or only the
head coach and oh CDC can talk I'm
curious how it all works yes they can
all talk okay
offense usually is only like the wide
receiver coach usually can't like buzz
into the defensive coordinator he
doesn't have that capability he does not
he could talk to other guys in the
offense but what will happen with like
wide receiver coaches you'll see they'll
have their thing on but they might have
the mic up because nobody wants to hear
from them they're in the game right like
until they're asked a question where the
coach might be like hey is that third
receiver still healthy and then he's got
to get on there in be like yeah coach is
ready you'll be ready to go 11 personnel
so the head coach is talking a lot the
head coach is talking both sides of the
ball coordinators or minors are talking
a whole lot that is anybody else getting
on the mic no not really I mean for the
most part whether it's just some
dialogue but really the offensive
coordinator and offensive coordinator
and can they hear each other I know like
the offensive defense there's not gonna
be any crossover like you're like Josh
McDaniels is not hearing what Matt
Patricius saying to easin they're on a
different line gotcha
right but Bill can look
switch over that's why you'll see the
cats which are all making switch back
and forth to know what they need to yes
interesting right so everybody the
offensive defense are dominating the
conversation the offensive coordinator
usually gonna have somebody in the booth
that he trusts where he's might be like
what coverage is that I wasn't sure and
somebody up there he's out there right
unless he's up there that communication
will go on but everybody else is really
just listening from their orders from
their offensive defensive coordinator do
they like say like 10-4 like over and
out no do they say hi do you think when
they come on they're like hey Josh hey
what's up bill do that no it's not like
that did you say goodbye
they're like Josh josh Josh yeah bill
yeah bill yeah do you have any funny
stories of like hearing the people
talking to each other I can't say that I
can remember anything overall I like
these questions from Peter like I never
thought of these questions yeah yeah
they're good they're good basic ones
that people don't think of any ghosts
and this is the weirdest question don't
judge me Peter we're not gonna judge
never not us do locker rooms have enough
showers for all the players where do
players have to wait for others to be
done showering yeah this time of the
year with 90 to 90 players on the roster
there's not 90 showers so yes so you're
telling me there's 53 showers for 53
guys no they all want to go with the
same time no there's not there's not 53
in the nice stadiums let me just say
let's say there's maybe I'm gonna just
like rough estimate 30 to 35 showers
right which is usually plenty not
everybody's running for the shower at
the same time some guys are getting
taped take it off some guys are doing
media some guys might just be talking to
a coach whatever it may be so for the
most part most stadiums are up to date
with like the showers but yeah you're
not either there's not 53 shower heads
for everybody to take one all at the
same time interesting question yes when
you go to an away game yeah is it
purposefully disgusting in their locker
room so do they make it bad like do they
make it bad showers and bad lockers for
you they make it not as good it's not
bad as well they make it pink that was I
mean Kansas State I believe did that
when I went and played there in college
like they make the whole college really
does that crap more
they NFL the NFL is like the
professional the league runs a lot of
these things we're not bad there's just
not the they're not as good right like
the shower is not quite as strong right
like I would make all of the showers
super leak yeah right like no water that
would piss off a team badly certainly
yeah but yeah and then some teams like
I've told you in the away locker rooms
they have their own trash barrels
because they don't even want to let the
stadium or that team have the trash
right so like if we were Tampa we were
going to play the Houston Texans in
preseason game number three it was our
trash we were taking the trash back with
us we weren't gonna let them see it at
all and yeah I mean you I've heard
stories about you know the Baltimore
Ravens when they went into New England
Stadium I've heard that they won down
the locker room Wow with FBI stuff to
make sure they're not being bugged they
bring their own garbage all that things
you know bring your own garbage to the
away locker room because there has been
stories about opposing teams going I
mean to the away hotel going to the way
hotel when the team is left and then
going into their dining room ago let me
see if any of these idiots left out
their first ten plays or first 15 plays
or ran yes
I just realized three hours ago Phil
Simms tweeted getting ready for some
football space question mark and deep
thoughts by the big [ __ ] I love the
idea of Simms being like I need to
interact more with my social media
Christopher because were you ever uses
Twitter but put out a question people
answer don't do it dad we are going
tomorrow to get our absolute face beaten
in I don't know if it's a hundred
percent confirmed but I'm gonna shoot my
shot and hope the universe follows
through Josh telling me not to a mother
there is a very very good chance that we
will have a very very special guest for
Wednesday's podcast Josh who has the
confidence of a flee does not want us to
announce it of a dying snail that's the
level of his confident he's are probably
pretty confident I feel pretty good oh
you think a snail's confident I know he
is pretty confident yeah just hop on
them yeah but Wednesday could be really
really special so stay tuned you're
gonna see updates at Sims
all forms of social media Twitter
Instagram the amount of interaction that
you guys have with us on the tour was
awesome
I knew we picked up a ton of new
followers so welcome
Wow what breaking is so yeah it's not
good for you
I'll Shawn Geoffrey unite not play the
first week of the year first I'll see
you P they're saying first six weeks
sorry
close the yearbook gone 2017 we'll see
and then in the next few weeks guys
we're going to be making our season long
predictions we're gonna have to each
pick our our playoff teams we're gonna
pick our MVP Rookie of the Year all that
stuff that'll be enough yeah be then I
like to do it right after week three of
the preseason I think that that's what I
feel like we know the most so for Simms
peace out homies for mr. pendrick good
evening everybody and for the lef koe
man we will holler at you guys later
haha guys thank you so much we'll talk
to you soon
hit us up on the reddit hit us up
Twitter Instagram at citizen Lefko you
guys are don't talk to you later he's